-I want to ask about the fact
that you have been covering
Black Lives Matter
as a movement since 2012.
Can you speak to, you know, how
you feel the movement has grown
and where you are currently at
in regards to optimism
or pessimism?
-Yeah, I mean, you know, when
I was covering even in 2012,
I was aware that,
you know, Black Lives Matter,
it started, you know,
during enslavement, right?
I mean, Black Lives Matter
is an age-old movement
that just changes names.
It's been
the Civil Rights Movement.
You know, it's been run by SNCC.
It's been run by the Southern
Christian Leadership Conference.
It's been John Lewis' movement.
You know,
it's been Dr. King's movement.
And you know, in 2012,
it really launched
just as the term
"Black Lives Matter."
You know, three Black queer
women launched this hashtag.
And it was around
Trayvon Martin, this kid
who's walking down the street
minding his own business.
He gets killed by somebody
who had an aspiration
of being a police officer.
So it had this sort of --
the flavor
of police violence
against Black bodies.
And so it launched around
this idea of saying, you know,
you need to think of these
young lives as being important,
and why we don't do that
in America is a big problem.
And so Black Lives Matter
launched.
And the thing that was so
different about then and now
is that at the time
you had a president
who was incredibly
empathetic to it.
He said, "If I had a son,
he'd have looked like Trayvon
or I could have been Trayvon."
You had that empathy
in the White House,
that desire
to embrace the movement,
bring them into the White House,
talk to them.
You know, Eric Holder was trying
to figure out, how could we work
with Black Lives Matter
to make the country better?
But the public was against them.
You know, the polling was
terrible for Black Lives Matter.
You know, white America
really rejected this movement
even when it was
Eric Garner and Michael Brown
and all of these people.
You know, Freddie Gray.
I covered the Freddie Gray
movement in the streets.
You're talking about a guy
who was thrown limp
into the back of a police car,
and there was still
very little empathy.
Even Tamir Rice,
who was a baby, 12 years old.
Nothing seemed
to move the public at large
other than Black folk
and Brown folk to be for it.
Now you have
the flip side of that.
It's completely upside down.
You have a president
who's completely unsympathetic
and hostile
to Black Lives Matter,
hostile to the idea
of people kneeling, you know,
saying that we want fairness
and justice from police.
But the public is now on
the Black Lives Matter
movement's side.
And that is a huge change,
and it's an important change.
You've now got
white folks out there
marching and
getting tear gassed.
Moms in Portland
getting tear gassed
for Black Lives Matter.
Before, it was Heather Heyer
putting her life on the line
and losing her life
for Black Lives Matter.
Now it's a bunch of moms,
and I think
it's an important difference
because it means it's broader.
This is not a niche movement.
It's not just
a Black people concern.
This is the public realizing if
they're coming for Black lives,
they're eventually
coming for yours.
They're eventually coming
for your security and peace.
All of us have to be
in this together.
I think that is actually
an important change.
And we're seeing legislation.
We're actually seeing it
become legislation.
So that's important.
-It's obviously also important
to have voices like yours
talking about this.
You're the only Black woman
anchoring a news show right now,
and we're really lucky
to have you doing that.
I want to leave by asking,
are you preferring these hours
to your "AM Joy" hours
when you hosted a morning show
on MSNBC?
-Well, yes and no.
Okay, so, on the "no" part,
two hours is like --
Think about how much you pay
for a 30-second
television commercial, right?
Two hours is like gold, right?
You have two whole hours.
So it's harder
to shrink myself...
and all the questions I have.
I have like a hundred questions
for Joe Biden.
I can only ask like 40 of them.
Right?
You have to shrink it down.
And also I love
having Mondays off.
People do not understand
Monday being Saturday
and Tuesday being Sunday
is everything.
You can get all your stuff done.
Nobody's in the stores.
It's, like, perfect.
So I'm going to miss
having Mondays and Tuesdays
as my weekend,
but I love these hours
in the sense
that it's immediate.
Like, I'm not analyzing the week
from the back end.
We're literally now front line,
every day, in the mix.
For a news junkie,
there's nothing better
than being on the air
every night in prime time.
It's just --
It's a fabulous opportunity.
-Well, congratulations again,
and hopefully when this
all clears up, we'll see
each other in the building.
All the best, Joy.
-I will wave through
the German tourists at you.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Sounds good.